[Music]
thank you
guys when Berkeley undergraduate so who
else here only has an undergraduate
degree
yes yes okay so a few of us die hard to
learn competing in the trenches or the
gutter as I like to say so Berkeley
undergrad his first job was in 1967 for
the Port Authority of New York so you
know when you get off the the bus and it
smells kind of funny over there
so I worked there for a year before
saying you know the east coast is kind
of cold and you want to come back to Bay
Area because Roots uh came back out here
in 86 working for
afterwards
where he started working on our tosses
for IBM including a supermarket project
with Safeway so back when you know real
time was actually real time
uh after that I worked on MBS 370 so
who's programmed in mvs 370 architecture
excellent
so uh hopefully we'll get a little War
Story Action from those times and in
um 78 started working on databases and
in 83 uh first released a db2 is that
that video right there Don correct
absolutely so um he became at IBM the
CTO for databases and content management
and in 2005 we're tired as an IBM fellow
his name his picture is on the wall of
IBM down at Almaden as one of the
database gurus from one of the great
database companies on the face of the
planet so uh with that introduction
let's hear what Don has to say about
database
thank you
so in
1960 60
5 when I was going in 4 63 52. there was
no comp side
they're with a comp
but there were no compsi
so there was a we had one uh software
course non-credited when I left which
was in four grand
and that was it but that was the state
of computer science in
1967-66. uh so we're going to do a
little uh the story here is history
repeats
so just for your Pete remember that and
and so every time that y'all come you
young folks come in to tell an old guy a
story we go I've seen that before
so this is a I've seen that before
but
that new thing
is applicable now
and that's what we're going to get to
okay
so the actually the the trip in the CTO
is
I've seen that before
but now is the time maybe you guys got
it okay so that's where we're gonna go
with this thing so the basic
architecture
um
we're going to start with a couple of
observations and the observation is uh
the basic architecture today so so this
is uh classic IBM where or classic
presentation you give the end first you
give the story and then you give the and
and it's to see if you're paying
attention Okay and we do that in IBM
because the executives never get beyond
the first chart so you want you take the
last chart you move it first because
that's where you're asking for the money
so here's here's the punchline give me
the money now here's the details so
that's uh the structure
so observation is that the the basic uh
architecture today database data
architecture today is Federated
and you all know what that is right it's
Federated and if I'd have said that like
30 years ago everybody are on
not it's monolithic you know you have
everything inside of your Oracle store
today forget it it's it is Federated
number two observation is
existing databases are good for doing
existing stuff
they don't do new stuff well they may do
new stuff they don't do new stuff well
if you really need it to be done well
you got to do something else
why simple
they get bloat I know I've created lots
of databases they get bloke you know
it's kind of like me you get blown and
and with bloat you get complexity and
you get commitment a commitment to it is
to a set of customers that you're going
to be doing X for this customer and why
for that customer and now you got a new
one that you want to do Z and it's not
really compatible with the X and Y so
you kind of do a little bit of what Z
needs to be done
and then you start to get bloating
complexity and complexity yeah okay so
So eventually the old databases grow and
try to satisfy some part of the market
but there's some catharsis that happen
some events have happened that the
demands something new and we're going to
go through a couple of those
and to work to the president
next observation is nothing ever goes
away
nothing ever dies
okay
how many of you were doing Computing in
the 1970s
oh now raise your hand because there's a
couple old farts in here but uh you must
have been okay in the 1970s so now the
quiz is there is a existing database
that is used in the IRS
that comes from the 1970s
what is the name of that database
next
hint
is it didn't come from IBM
model 204
model 204 is an inverted file system
that is still used for the core
processing of your tax returns
see I'm getting a one guy over here that
he actually looks about my age and he's
like oh my God
nothing ever goes away okay which is
going to lead us to whatever choices
you're making today it is not going to
go away
my brother worked in uh in uh for NASA
and the stuff that's up on the satellite
that he created in the 1960s
it's still up to the satellites
okay so nothing goes away
uh I made some notes on my way here
[Laughter]
that
stores always start simple
so I'm going to give you some examples
so remember I've given you the last
chart first Federated old things do gold
things well hard to make them do new
things
and a new thing starts simple
and they always start
with a KV
which is just CI Sam renamed
so it's just an index store
and or
a very shallow hierarchy everybody knows
hierarchy
two level everybody knows two level
right
so you end up doing a two level
hierarchy in there which is Don
all the stuff related to Don that's it
okay so they start simple and then they
grow to satisfy another particular
market and that's what we're going to go
through because we're in a shift there's
a couple of shifts that's going on
okay those those are there today
the new stores have to consume
a lot
they have to be elastic I know we
overuse that one but I'm going to tell
you what elastic really means
and
they have to do data Discovery because a
phenomena has happened over the last 50
years
which is we have slowly migrated to
where the data that we have inside the
Enterprise
was all internal
50 years ago
40 years ago
30 years ago
it all came from inside
as we moved from the 1990s and into 2000
the bulk of the data comes from outside
in the early part back there 50 years 40
years 30 years ago
we thought we could pull it with a data
model to guarantee what the data looked
like now on the I.T side we are simply
reacting we are reacting and the
database has to be part of that reaction
it is no longer a pre-planned event if
what is going on right now and how do I
consume it integrate it in and make it
make sense
okay so time to consumption is
everything we saw that shift happen
in the 1980s but I'll get to there
so this is a little history of the
database
1960s
database how many were around in 1960s
how many were even just around in the
1960s
okay how many were working in Computing
in the 1960s to say oh come on
I'm the only guy that was working the
1908 thank you thank you very much
so in the 1960s we had
two database Styles going on it was just
getting started and this was saber
right on the airline control system and
that was a KV store that was just an
index store and we had idms and IMS and
these were harmful databases and network
databases
and the way that reading the database
started was because the hardware was so
lousy the disc would fail all the time
and so they were there to make sure that
you could go and figure out what the
data would really looked like because we
were constantly recovering and restoring
stuff that's how we got started was
lousy discs as opposed to the day where
we have lousy member
so lousy discs
and they were not generally available in
fact if you looked around in companies
at the end of the 1960s you would have
found about uh six ten companies or so
that you would have known about other
than military that was using this sort
of stuff
we used it in Airline control as I said
and we used it down in uh tracking auto
parts for Airlines and that's where the
hierarchical database
so as we so like I said it was
it we had these lousy desks
and we had time to get through some of
this data
as we went into the 1970s oh by the way
our availability requirements in the
1960s
was to try to stay up eight hours a day
five days a week that was our
availability okay and there was a single
application for The Neighbors
you do not have multiple applications
for the day there was an application for
today
when I moved into the 1970s and was we
go through the 1970s these higher purple
databases and the uh
KV databases
kicks had one which was file store uh
file controlled uh they started to be
used but we're going to get to the end
because by the end of 1980s
what percentage of the Enterprise is how
even a single database from their entire
shop we're going to take a guess what's
your nails what percentage
end of the 80s
30 to 50 percent he's hedging his bets
okay
what you you weren't there what's your
thoughts
do I have more than 50 40 44 4 percent
five percent the answer was 25 a quarter
of the Enterprise by the end of the
1970s
have one at least a database in their
shop this is 1970s
idms IMS harkerville databases Rule the
Day
application
database
not two applications database one
application for the database otherwise
things got all screwed up by the end of
the 1970s
availability requirements were
10 hours a day
five and maybe a half a day
okay
so
that it wasn't widespread and developing
an application
the key requirement as we came through
the end of 1970s that we uh I mean if I
went around to 100 Enterprises
and I asked what is it you want me to do
the answer was I have a two and a half
year backlog on application business
responding my business two and a half
year backlog and I can't do it with that
stuff
how do I get and there and and until
you're two and a half years I mean I'm
and it's growing it's growing so it'll
be three four five years in other words
they can't respond to their business
so meanwhile relational technology they
started to pop up right it was invented
if you will in the 1970s
and relational technology
database
in a market
we were responding to two things one is
there was really no database in the unit
and so Oracle went into units
which was used by engineers
to track their stuff
and the second was the major Enterprise
the parts of the Enterprise which were
not the engineering side of the
Enterprise which were using you know IBM
stuff AP stuff
and what those guys wanted again was
something that was going to speed
application development
at some price it was going to end up
costing them a little bit more
so db2 came out as did
others responding to that and people go
oh it was a relational model
no it was not the relation law
what
answer
so in the 1970s to develop an
application
for IMS
for idms
you didn't take them the system offline
regen the database reboot the database
system
identify what applications you work to
that database management system because
they were not dynamically introduced
they were jammed into the system
and then you brought it up and you
tested it
and it came down
now
machines were very expensive
when do you think that we got machine
shots
the answer was some of you may remember
that I said requirements were up 10
hours a day
five and a half days a week
and you might think well we got night
time
no nighttime was backing out the system
what we got was weekends so we got one
shot every weekend
for a new application
okay
how long do you think it's going to take
you to work out your application a very
long time
so what happened with these new
relational products that came out
you could dynamically create a database
you could dynamically introduce a new
application
without bringing the system down
this was like a hundred-fold increase
you could I mean I could give you a
little testing thing which you looked at
angle
well you know that's not too Innovative
this is 1970. this was very Innovative
okay
so the point of that
statement is
what are we trying to respond to
with the technology it's not about the
technology it's not about relational
databases what problem are we trying to
solve for the customer and a customer
problem then was
two and a half year backlog
how do I make application development
faster
so relational was terrific because I
could show an executive I mean I could
show an executive in business
a select star from and he went I
understand that
I could go and show an executive
a network DPG Cobalt request and he'd
say what is that I don't understand that
so right off the bat with the relational
he understood
then I showed them that by golly we
could make application development on
the same 100 times faster
but it was going to cost you seven times
more in compute cost
and he went
well I see the employee suggestion
program that's probably a good one I'll
put that one in there you know so
something that had low volume not used
much and I'll wait for Moore's law to
catch up and that's what happened
okay
so here it is in the 19
80s that we introduced
relational database targeting that
in the 1970s
if you wanted any information out of the
database
you got a programmer
okay you've got a programmer it had to
be programmed users didn't get access to
data they're really somebody will tell
you there were bi tools instead of
baloney there were no bi tools and they
and the database wasn't understood you
had to get a programmer to program to it
biggest godsend was 1972 when what came
out
RPG
because that's what we created reports
in Okay so y'all didn't touch the
database the data store it all you had
to get a programmer to do it
so there we were in the 1980s and the
big opportunity was providing some tool
to so you could get access to the
information
but remember this is the 1980s
so how many had parents in the 1980s
how many of your parents understood
Computing in the 1980s
three we got three let's raise the hands
again how many had parents in the 1980s
you had no parents in the 1980s
did you have parents in the 1980s
oh I'm sorry how about your mother
okay so so we had three hands come up to
say that they understood it and that's
about the size of the thing you know we
didn't have an audience that understood
computers and we definitely didn't have
tools that would allow that audience to
look at it it was programmed
so
while this relational thing came out and
we were all excited
that it was addressing this this backlog
remember it was seven to ten times I'm
being really generous say it was seven
times the cost because I I didn't relate
I did the TV too you know there were
instances there were five like 100 times
the cost but burn lots he was the leader
of IMS and he died so I no longer have
to uh to respond
so so meanwhile
is important
while relation was taking off there was
a very special need it was going on
the banks of Japan oh
the banks of Japan wanted
a database system transactional system
that would run 24x7
never go down
and run like blazingly fast
doesn't matter what we call blazingly
fast at that time it was like 10 to 100
times whatever it is that you could buy
on the street
and that's where
IMS backpacking
and so what was IMS fact so here we have
this this flow going on of this
relational thing everybody buy a new
relational wrong uh and we have this
other need over here which is really
high performance of the 1980s really
high availability and it's met by an a
offshoot coming out of the higher Google
database and what was the structure of
IMS fast app
remember I started the whole thing and
saying it always starts with two models
what are those two models
it always starts with the KB model
that's what I'm as fast as
a KB model simply an index on top of the
thing
and it always starts with a shallow
hierarchy two level hierarchies we're
called ddbs
that's IMS Fastpass
all the data was kept in memory as best
we could and we were and we did group
commit which was like the novel thing in
that time and we could run blazingly
fast
so while the rest of the world was
looking at this relational stuff
you know we had this other thing which
is this need for very high availability
very high performance it was going on
and we made a ton of money
out of banks of Japan were running on
that stuff all the way through to when
now
correct
that is correct and
it went down
the system went down for the first time
about three years ago
for I don't know
a couple hours an hour or something like
that front page news and the CEO of IBM
had to personally go over and apologize
okay so we have a major theme going on
which is release the database coming out
to handle all this stuff over here and
we have this high performance high
performance high performance High
availability thing
we're going to see that repeat it again
in the 1980s PC started but but PC is
for PCs they were personal computers
people were getting in the spreadsheets
but it wasn't like
being used heavily inside of firms it
was Private it was personal uh we didn't
even again I asked how many people
understood Computing and the thought
parents understood community in 1980s
and the answer is not many you know the
guys that were understood Computing in
the 1980s were like 15 year olds and 25
year olds and they weren't doing
spreadsheets in Enterprises
but friendship came
notes came
with email and handling stuff
non-structured stuff there was no
non-structured stuff there's all past
structure but non-structured stuff
and what is the structure of a node's
database
it's a shallow two-level hierarchy
apparent and all the junk that you have
all the records associated with that
it's big table
okay
so
so we had that but if you looked inside
the enterprise we were doing email but
it was like casual communication but
blah blah blah
that was a mistake
so whatever happened to your own
business side in the 1980s was something
called
lbs levered buyouts
everybody knows a leopard buyout is
right
what was happening was
the guys inside the Enterprise didn't
understand what the value of their
assets were they weren't paying
attention to their data that they had
the guys on the outside were paying
attention to what is the value of this
building what is the value of that
camera what is the value of all the
assets
and so they buy just sell all the stuff
it was a leverage buyout and so we had a
whole bunch of companies just kind of at
that point when we better get our arms
around the data and understand what it
is because we're at risk
we're at big risk this was happening
like crazy second event was going on
mergers
by this time we had a whole bunch
of companies Enterprises that were using
computers to do their stuff in the 1970s
if you went to the bank
there was a stack of paper of that bank
that was your cat listed your account if
I went to my Branch he'd look it up and
he'd figure out how much I had there and
he she would write in what I was taking
out and then give me the money
that was the 1970s and if I went to a
different branch they'd call my branch
and then somebody would do that
towards the end they were doing both
they were doing the computer and they
were still writing on the paper
in the 1980s they gave up the paper
whoa
this was a big deal
so by the by the end of the 1980s we had
HR and we had all the basic business
processes in most of the Enterprises
computerized
we now went for burgers
oh my God now I gotta go your HR System
merged with my HR System and your
Finance system merged with my finance
system and your merged with my and
you're merged with mine and it was like
a nightmare
okay common parchment
and so the answer at that point was
let's go and use just a couple of
databases let's put everything into sap
and then hopefully when we merge
together we will make our life simple
so is that what really happened
no that's not what really happened what
really happened is the grunts had to go
in you know and provide Bridges between
all these things we had to Federate the
stuff
and then try to smoosh it in eventually
to get rid of the Federation but do we
ever really get rid of anything
no no we don't
okay so by the end of 1980s
Number One requirement out of db2
was availability
stay up 24 hours a day by the end of
1980s stay up 24 hours a day why because
they got rid of the paper
that got rid of the paper
stamped 24 hours a day six days a week
not seven six days so we had one day to
install software do backups and all that
sort of stuff
okay uh so so we that that was the
requirement accept this extreme case
right which I talked about which is 24x7
now we're going to put the net clicker
in here
worldwide
I want you up 24 by seven
so now remember what networking
technology looked like back around 1980s
do you think there was just one instance
of this thing running in Japan no there
was an instance running here and this
and so you had this handoff going around
the world right
and that's where tandem Etc had great
success
great success
handing off copying hand you know
handing off okay
to run a worldwide operation
okay
so now we get into the 1990s the rent
and people go well 1990s that's internet
now that's when the internet started
we we saw starting on the internet when
we're in the Enterprise then we didn't
see people in the there doing all these
intermitting things we just almost
started it okay so the the dominant
amount of data that we saw in the 1980s
was came from inside
remember that inside because there's
been a big shift here
if we were under the 1990s with the
internet
by the way I'm ignoring object databases
because that would take me about a half
an hour to tell you where they lived in
this whole picture
so in the 1990s internet's getting
started
now what percentage of the Enterprise is
using databases
thank you Hunter
not 9 800.
so by 1990 100
okay is using databases of some form
transaction systems
with databases underneath them we get
into them but
it's all internally driven data
remember I said the other problem was
The Leverage buyout people knew more
about you than you knew about yourself
started we're going to get there and
companies
that are in the Internet space
Amazon Yahoo
Google
they'll look around and say what's the
infrastructure I mean I need to do
something here to run this stuff
and existing technology didn't work
they needed something elastic what was
elastic and then we'll tell why they
needed laughter
elastic was then I needed to go from
running One processor to a thousand
processors in 10 seconds
and why because the marketing model
wasn't the old marketing model old
marketing model of JC Penney's is I'm
going to have this new piece of
propeller I try it over here in Dayton
Ohio I see how it plays out in Dayton I
figure out how many I'm going to order
three months later I move it over to
Memphis Tennessee I work that one out
now I do a roll you know worldwide
rollout
what's the new model on the in the
internet the new model on the Internet
is put it out see if it sticks
see if they respond it's now available
to everybody
and then if it not able to respond
how do you think the reaction is going
to be of your customer set
you're down to two you know you go to
Amazon and the thing is down
well no have to expand or does it have
to go from one processor to a thousand
processors in like that because you have
a hot product
and you don't know it because you can't
predict it
so the new market the time the market
model changed
and elastic was that capability
and then you have to have this other
capability was I just went like that you
had to shrink
because Suddenly at 10 o'clock at night
it wasn't being used but somebody else
had and you had to shrink
the second
part in elasticity was
we now had
new data coming from everywhere
information coming from everywhere
it wasn't pre-planned we didn't agree to
what it looked like you didn't talk to
my dbas and we get it all modeled and
worked into the Enterprise it just
showed up
it just showed up
and so we needed the elastic
infrastructure to be able to
handle an elastic data model one that
just showed up those were the two things
that responded to
so then we had one instance of one
company that ended up taking Oracle and
trying to glue a whole bunch of them
together
because it wasn't elastic in terms of
being able to expand so they had to
build an infrastructure above that we
had another one which said I'm going to
go to start from scratch
because that's not working out I keep on
fighting these guys
what were the data model that these guys
were using that said we're going to
start from scratch
KB
and bigtable
KB big table right
an index
on top a little index database system
and a little shallow hierarchy here's
all the stuff related and done it's all
nearby one another if the guy wants Don
he gets all the stuff related and done I
hope that's what he wants because if he
wants stuff related you know some cross
section of this well it's going to stand
but that's where we started
so while we had relational databases
taking off like crazy Oracle db2
Microsoft you know the main thing over
here the side was this new name
for an elastic Enterprise
built on that data model
24x7 worldwide
that's a requirement
no question about it
application development time now
that's the requirement
meanwhile
I have as fast path is going like crazy
tpf is running all the airline systems
because it's tailored to that particular
usage model
so you got this mainstream going on and
you've got this high performance thing
and then eventually you've got this new
structure in the Enterprise and that's
what we are now in the 2000s right so
here we are in the 2000s
we've gone off to the cloud
the cloud it could be private it could
be publicly we want to have access to
Computing resources from anywhere
and
that's where we end up with
these new databases
and that's the nosql new SQL set I'm not
here hyping is saying uh
I got up this morning
I went for two hour hike with my brother
who's 74.
we had lunch
I met up with my
uh one of my grandkids
and his friend we went out we did
swimming in the pool we played foosball
I'm set I don't need this okay
okay
I just came for the dinner
okay so that's likely alarmed to get out
of these things as a dinner
so but that's the new infrastructure
highly elastic so it's not just on the
internet I mean look at JCPenney is what
a problem they have look at all how fast
time the market is everything now time
to Market is the winner it's the best
SSD ever going to make it no what's
going to make it is the guy that gets
there first
and has a three months Edge over anybody
else
time the market is everything and that's
what we have to respond to at the
Enterprise
at the Enterprises providing a
infrastructure so they can
get there
now time the market no Inhibitors no two
and a half year of backlog of
application
now
so
that that's where the the subsets
after that thing came comes a structure
we talked about the fact that in the
1980s
we still the PC arrived
and we started to have tools that would
allow somebody other than a professional
programmer to access the things
I don't mean a casual user because the
1980s you know and anybody outside of
Silicon Valley didn't understand how to
use you know Max
or PCS very well and we went in 1990s
everybody knew that knows how to use
that stuff so end user access to this
stuff
the we now have how do I get
analytics on all this information coming
in from all these different places where
today it is the dominant information is
coming from outside not inside
DBA is not in control of the data model
he is reacting to the data model it is
coming in and his job is to sort it out
and try to figure out what makes sense
after the fact he's reacting so you
build a reactionary infrastructure you
introduce the stuff and then I go and I
tell you you know that stuff you're
getting off Wiki
it really stinks
okay that's my job as a DBA back in the
1980s I said I'm not going to make Wiki
available to you until I guarantee it
was all right now I say you're gonna get
it now I react to you getting it and I
figure out
it's not all right and you're and you're
building a business off of this thing
that's reactionary
with
the day we talk about
the
infrastructure
and the database infrastructure now has
to expand
to be able to take on the Analytics
of the Enterprise
what does that mean
remember back in the 1980s we ended up
putting out relational with a fixed set
of function
right do some count average whatever
and then somewhere at the end of 1980s
1990s we put in extensibility you can
provide your own function
didn't really work out very well
what were some of the problems long talk
didn't work out real well
we now move into where we are today
you've got to be able to make the
database
on a platform play to be able to run
the Analytics
of the Enterprise you have to be able to
paralyze it Hadoop map bar they're just
another instance of this thing which is
a data store where they're able to
paralyze it
Okay so we've got this little thing
going on here which is I need a
parallelization platform
these guys are introducing here
UDS
UDF says a method of introducing
application function into the database
but you have to be you have to paralyze
this stuff and yeah there's a lot of
work to be done there
but as we go through the next decade the
database becomes the platform for
analytics and it must incorporate
your Analytics not the ones I dream of
your analytics it must paralyze them
they must pipeline them if it doesn't
we'll just be the database just becomes
a KV store
the platform for analytics is above
so that's where we are today what what
happens as we go through the next
let's say five six seven years
so in this world the
data more data comes from outside to
come from inside
more data come from outside than this
side
we could probably find out more about
you than you know about you
which leads us all to concerns of
privacy
businesses only care a little bit about
what they really care about
is
protection of their assets
that's what they really care about
have they revealed assets who are the
key players that are inside the firm who
are going to get raided by somebody else
what is the real books what's on the
books for uh selling for the next
quarter what's going to happen over the
next three quarters do you know more
than they know
very concerned with that
so it's really the protection of their
asset but suddenly we've opened this
thing up and it's and and everybody's
getting healthy shelters going on
everywhere
we're seeing that in Securities industry
Health industry government military
everywhere
so where is this opened up
how do we end up protecting preventing
and then verify it remember we said the
wiki thing
right how much of the wiki stuff is true
how much of the stuff that is coming
over is true how much of the stuff
you're reading emails is true
there there you go responsibility of the
I.T shop dbas is to guarantee to provide
some value of the assets
and so we've opened it up and this is a
big can of worms right now
for Enterprises on the top
okay protection of their assets
so integrate validate verify
so Federation complexity is rising
polynomial I don't know big you know I
knew that you're all doing a new data
store every year you're all every year
every day you know every minute and I
told you model 204 is still running
as the base
for our tax system
this my brother's code is running up on
some satellite
okay this stuff is going to be here
forever
and we'll make any decisions so you have
to choose well
okay
so nothing goes away so I started out
with saying that the punch line is it's
going to be a Federated
old things do old things very well
oracle's not going away db2 is not going
away it's going to do what it's doing
and it's going to do it very well it's
doing it well
I have a staff path of doing well
what is the database system that's used
for airlines
you're right it's ppf
okay that must be in your father
when you book something okay that's
safer they're still using these same
database systems
and I told you nothing to throw it away
new things for new things that are
really important
for new things are important
and so that major little shift that we
had is this shift to where agility
to be able to be elastic in our
infrastructure respond to the business
now and being able to react and I need a
data infrastructure to do that and
that's what this new guys are focusing
on
okay so that's the shift that's
happening now
I'm done
thank you